here on the Millea Peninsula and Uganda
Africa some banded mongooses have
discovered a termite swarm they swarm on
the swarm and then predator turns prey
when the mongooses nemesis the marabou
stork appears while the mongooses are
busy with the termites the marabou
storks have their sights set on the
Mongoose babies
[Music]
the pack stands fast trying to fight off
the storks these mongooses are no
pushover they're famous for fighting and
killing snakes including Cobras so it's
not surprising they can fight off some
marabou storks even though these birds
are 5 feet tall and have wing spans of 8
and a half feet the mongooses are barely
pushing 2 feet
tail included how long can these scrappy
little fighters hold off the largest
storks in the world
[Music]
the mother Mongoose enters 7 pups have
now taken refuge in this stack of
fishing boats the marabou stork swoops
in still looking to snatch a young one
one of the pops is ventured outside the
boats
dad makes a save just in time then he
does his best to distract the big birds
but the storks seem to be getting cranky
they came for a pup and they won't be
tonight the mongooses abandon ship and
look for more secure turf soon the
parents find a new home but where there
are mongoose pups there will soon be
four raesha storks and the battle is on
a third time
[Music]
one pup gets separated and just like
that a stork takes him off
despite the packs best effort the storks
win this battle and moms brood numbers
only six